good evening and yes I'm currently in in
my apartment in the Bayeux Lu district
in the center of Istanbul on the
European side I live just off a street
called Istiklal Caddesi which is really
assembles equivalent of Oxford Street a
very busy shopping district at the
moment I can see that there's been a few
a few different for the crowds of people
running sort underneath my apartment
there's it's not not clear exactly
what's happening but it seems like
there's some sort of disturbance on
Istiklal Caddesi as well
and have you heard any military aircraft
there are reports of jets and
helicopters flying low there's also
we've seen pictures of tanks at the
airport as well as military vehicles
blocking off those bridges over the
Bosphorus if you have you been able to
witness any of that from your apartment
I heard two helicopters within the last
20 minutes which in itself is not
entirely unusual but but combined with
the bridges being closed and the tanks
of the airport and and and the reports
from television it seems to sort of
combine - yes to be some sort of
military coup and it would appear and
how do you feel about that living there
in Istanbul as an expat living I've
lived here for a year and a half the
frequency with which sort of security
incidents that have occurred in Istanbul
this year it's becoming more of a
regular feature so you combining those
terrorist attacks with with the military
coup it's certainly a concern I think
but perhaps laughter - to sleep on it
tonight and then and and and see what
tomorrow brings